i'm definitely a contender without a
doubt i mean it's definitely there
uh baker and the gang of uh involved to
annie made this team an
unbelievable team and a team you have to
prepare for and take serious
you know i think that moving forward
without a doubt i can see a lot more
playoff games between us and
you know i'll just take it one day at a
time and hope for it but
i think that uh you know the browns and
chiefs are definitely
neck and neck
boy so much for sucking up to patrick
mahomes
remember when we had travis kelsey as
one of the top wingmen mahomes is part
owner of the royals what are you doing
with the indians gear on
although we know what he's doing he's
pandering and that puts travis kelsey's
comments into perspective he was in
cleveland
when he said that he regards the browns
as a top contender
to the chiefs and they start the season
playing each other i don't think that
that's necessarily a great thing for the
browns but
if you're going to catch the chiefs i
don't know i
i don't i think you'd rather catch him
in the middle of october when maybe
they're not paying the kind of attention
they'd be paying to week one you know
andy reid's so good when he has two
weeks to get ready give him seven months
to get ready i think he's gonna
i think he's gonna have his guys ready
for whatever the browns may do chris but
i don't know are you buying this from
kelsey i am i'm buying it
i mean i think we need to i think
cleveland's the real deal
you know i really do you know you just
you look at the football team on paper
there's really not a weakness of the
team they've gotten better in the off
season in the areas they needed to
address there's no doubt about that
it's year two in the system odell
beckham jr should be back
and healthy i mean yes the windows here
it's it's legit you know and you're
right i mean andy reid's a magic man as
far as weak ones are concerned and all
those type of things but man
it won't be easy not with like this
running attack coming to town and
everything that they can do with this
this cleveland football team so no i
mean i think that the time has arrived
right i mean
i don't i don't say playoff window i
think cleveland is
like clearly in the super bowl window
have a super bowl football team and
wouldn't be shocked if they were there
you know come february next year
we saw what happened two years ago when
the bar was high for the browns
and they had one of their best seasons
in years of course the bar was low from
that perspective but
people thought they'd be a playoff team
in 2019 they failed miserably in part
because they decided to make freddie
kitchens the head coach all due respect
now the bar's high again and
we we just have to wait and see how the
browns
handle that right the fact that there
are
expectations the fact that the browns is
the browns is no longer the applicable
catchphrase
teams will start circling cleveland
in a positive way not well this is
essentially a bye week
no this is an a game measuring stick
week because everybody is on the browns
and
i don't know how they're going to deal
with that that they're going to have to
though
if they have aspirations to to match the
expectation that you have and
every team has that aspiration yeah and
they do it i wouldn't bet against them
at this point
but i want to see how they do especially
week one i mean they come out and beat
the chiefs week one
oh yeah that's the shot heard around the
football world no doubt about it i mean
you're right
they got the talent to match up with
them they do i mean i think if we broke
down both rosters and we went down like
position group by position group i think
it'd be a lot closer
if not advantage cleveland really in
some ways
it could i think it would be really
close but yeah
i you know mike that is the
million-dollar question success how can
they handle it all of those type of
things you're right
you know from what we saw last year
though i i
i would think that they continue to
handle it in the right way
i would we saw maturity throughout the
football team
we saw less you know
press conference antics from from baker
mayfield for the most part
we saw him really be a mature leader on
and off the field
they really handled themselves on and
off the field as an organization the
right way
all year that's where i give kevin
stefanski a lot of credit
you know and yeah they have a style of
football
that really fits their football team
their roster it all makes sense
i mean it really does so that's where i
come back to it to look at it and go man
there is no excuses
you're right though you know they have
reached a level i think of
yes went to the playoffs and players are
smart enough to know
like well they're going to look at oh we
got to play cleveland this week and
they're going to look at the roster and
see a little film and go whoa they're
the real deal we got to have a good week
like so they're not going to sneak up on
anybody you're right about that too
and it's going to be about how they can
handle it but i i don't know i'm
expecting positive results i really am
let's rip through the position groups
and you mentioned mayfield look there
was a lack of discipline in his game in
2019
generally yeah possibly because he
wasn't getting the coaching that he
needed
whether it was how to behave at press
conferences or his footwork
his throwing mechanics you had noticed
that he was kind of all over the place
in 2019 when freddie kitchens was the
coach
where where do you put the quarterbacks
now recognizing that case keenum is the
backup in the event that there's an
injury to baker mayfield well i mean we
got one of the best backups in football
in case keenum so even if baker goes
down your team's not going to fall off
you know earth here
they're going to have a chance to still
win football games and be successful
he knows the offense he fits that and
then i think baker mayfield's
on the edge of super stardom i mean from
the way he played last year
i mean he is certainly in that top
10-ish
quarterback conversation you know the
one thing that like i
jumped out to me with baker mayfield
when i went back and i'm doing my chris
sims top 40 corn
countdown i you know i watch film just
to hey let me look at some things let me
write some notes things that jump out to
me i mean baker mayfield's throwing
decision making
was top notch last year and like degree
of difficulty throwing mike
was special he wasn't getting like you
know the jared goff here's a guy three
feet in front of me in the flat
or here's another guy in front of me in
the flat and throw it to him and you run
from there
it was roll out oh there's a guy 23
yards down the field
he's got this much space that's how much
he's opened by shum he just let a rifle
out and throw it
aggressive high degree of difficulty
throwing with high degree
of success uh so yeah i'm i'm big on
baker right now i'd be shocked if he
doesn't hit the ground running
and he got better as the year went on
and a lot of that was the kevin
stefanski influence now you got a full
offseason now baker and
other offensive players haven't been
there for much of the off-season
because of the whole nflpa thing and jc
tretter the starting center for the
browns is the guy leading the charge to
get guys to stay away
but the thinking is in year two he'll
pick up where he left off and maybe
continue his development it is only his
fourth nfl season
running backs nick chubb entering his
fourth season contracting they have to
figure out what to do with him kareem
hunt
they have him signed for several more
years at a bargain basement price
they will be together for at least one
more year that's the best tandem in the
nfl
right right i don't i don't i don't
think anybody messes with this crew
right here
there's no way they do both things
really well and kareem hunt you know we
know he can even be
add more in the passing game they're
both number one like
number one starting running backs i mean
it's special they don't miss a beat when
either guy comes out of the game
chubb is amazing running between the
tackles and to me is one of the three or
four best running backs in the game
and hunts just on the outside edge of
that and has more value in the pass game
so
yeah i'm with you i mean that's to me i
they're nobody that's the best in the
game
tight ends and receivers fascinating
with obj
coming back jarvis landry touting
beckham's overall
preparedness and fitness and how he
looks coming back from that torn acl he
suffered while trying to make a tackle
against the bengals
fairly early in the season beyond landry
and obj you've got donovan peoples jones
rashard higgins he signed a one-year
deal to stick around with the team
at tight end you got austin hooper big
free agent acquisition
a year or two ago harrison bryant david
njoku who's in the final year of his
rookie deal
this is a pretty good group as well i
mean if obj's healthy yeah if ob
even if he's not healthy it's a pretty
good group if he's healthy you go
wait this is one of the better units in
football i mean that's you got two
really good tight ends
you know you got both of them we know
those two receivers even if obj's not
there higgins is real damn good too
donovan people jones showed a little bit
of talent last year
then the kid they drafted auburn anthony
schwartz this year in the in the draft
he can go so yes another unit where you
look at and go
it's towards the top of football and can
be scary good
if obj is healthy to what you say to
where you go i mean they
they have the potential to be right mike
i mean i don't know you tell me if i'm
crazy
really one of the two or three best
groups in football i think if obj comes
through the way we
we think he's capable of yeah i
i agree with you completely and uh
holding it all together the offensive
line
the offensive line has to get it done if
baker mayfield is going to have time to
do what he needs to do if the running
backs are going to have holes to run
through
what do we think about their offensive
line relative to others
in the conversation for the best in
football this is not like a broken
record this is real
you could argue it's the best guard
combo in football with betonio and wyatt
teller
you could go it's there's not a two
better on a team in the game
you know we know treader is is one of
the best centers in football
you know and then jack conklin who's one
of the better right tackles of football
jedrick wills he was good last year not
great but he got better as the year went
on
so you look at them and go they already
are a top five offensive line
you know now that's just like can they
be the absolute best can they be a force
like we saw the cowboys four and five
years ago or it's just like
we knew they were gonna run the ball
with ezekiel there's nothing we could do
they just smashed us and that was it
you know they have the chance to be that
to basically be like hey kansas city
yeah we're pulling this guard and we're
gonna run nick chubb right
here there's nothing you can do about it
that's how good this group is they could
be that dominant
and uh look you still have to have a
defense you're gonna get into a bunch of
shootouts and it could be that the
browns end up in some high scoring games
especially if their offense does what we
think he can do but defensively
with miles garrett with todavian
clowning we know with clowney comes the
giant
asterisk of him staying healthy but
good lord the idea of those two guys
even if it's half the season
with clowney and garrett complementing
that offense
i can see why travis kelsey said what he
said it
isn't just pandering to the folks in
cleveland i think he recognizes
that browns could be a force to be
reckoned with this year i don't know how
you can
if you're just paying attention to
football you know yeah you're right like
clowny but
we know garrett's in the conversation
for one of the best in football
they need like one of these d tackles to
come through a little bit
you know andrew billings the guy they
got from the bengals you know two years
ago
opted out right so now he's back in the
fold he could be a run stopper there in
the middle for them and their team
uh you know they they need a jordan
elliott who they drafted two years ago
in the third round of missouri
maybe a malik jackson helps out they got
it it's just we gotta
we gotta see just how good they're gonna
be there in the middle we know on the
edge they have a chance to be really
special
but then you add into like they got
anthony walker and free agency and got
jeremiah wusu coramoa in the second
round who we talked about a million
times i mean
he was definitely one of the 20 best
players in the draft he had a heart
murmur
and got and ended up falling to the
second
you know so they got a linebacker that
fits their scheme perfectly and you just
go
damn front seven really damn good i'm
not gonna say top five but it's got the
potential to be that
yeah and uh that'll secure moa thing
they were thinking about taking them in
round one
and all indications have been that the
heart issue is a non-issue
unbelievable to think how how big of a
steal he could be
how good that defense could be to go
along with an offense i mean something
special is brewing with the browns but i
still hear juju smith schuster and
i think fans hear it too the browns is
the browns you're so used to being
beaten down
you're so used to the team being bad
whether you are on the outside
or on the inside there still is a kind
of a wait and see
that they're ha and and that i think
that's just
that's perfect because even though the
bar seems to be high
there's still that nagging doubt and
maybe that keeps guys motivated keeps
guys focused
keeps guys from getting complacent and
this team does go out
and uh take over the afc and maybe the
nfl this year it would be amazing if
that happens
i i would think like the history
is gonna keep the team on edge a little
bit like they can't feel like oh we're
here
we've arrived so i i would have a hard
time believing that and i would think
the fan base is
yeah to a degree kind of gonna be you
know a little nervous
like wait what's gonna happen are we
gonna crap the bed like we've seen us do
here you know like you've talked about
with expectations high all of a sudden
we fall apart
i have a hard time believing that but
yeah like this generation of
people or anybody really younger than me
i mean they have nothing to no reason to
think cleveland can turn around or do
anything what
good you know again we grew up in an era
where yeah i in the early 80s the
mid-80s all through the 80s
you know i yeah the history of the
browns was relevant then in the 60s and
70s but
the 80s they were damn good i mean they
were a super bowl contender
for the last half more than the last
half of that decade
uh and and so the modern day kid the kid
that's
born around the 2000s they got no clue
that cleveland's
ever been you know worth a damn other
than jim brown
the back-to-back afc championship game
losses to the broncos yeah from the
drive
to the fumble and and uh yeah they were
there and then of course that team
became the ravens and won a couple of
super bowls but you're not allowed to
say that
ravens fans get upset when they're
reminded that they were once the browns
browns fans get upset that the ravens is
the browns not the browns is the browns
before we put a bow on this
secondary uh i mean look great front
seven
and we have a great front seven you
don't need a great secondary you and i
could play in the secondary but they got
guys a lot better than you and i they do
in the secondary
right now they the that's where like
they're they play that seattle scheme
where we talk about you don't need a lot
of great man-to-man corners but they got
a guy in denzel ward
who if he could stay healthy is one of
the 10 best cover corners in the game
so he's like that's legit and then the
fact that they got greg newsom
a big long great ball skills corner from
northwestern in the first round like
there's i mean again it's just another
position group where you go
okay yeah it's not proven but man the
talent's there it's real
i mean john johnson and free agency from
the rams to get him
grant delpid was a second round pick
from two years ago
towards acl last year in training camp
he'll be ready to go
so a little bit of unproven commodity
there greedy williams was hurt most of
last year
but like man top end young
speed talent it's there that might be
the biggest question mark on the
on the team though just because it's a
little unproven right but i think
it's just like okay let's see what they
got but i don't question and go oh
they're under man they got issues here
you know i i still go well there's great
potential here for this to be one of the
better units in football
troy have the potential to be one of the
best teams in football
amazing yeah if it does i i can't it's
going to take us a while to get used to
it but start getting used to it because
the browns are coming
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports